Okay. We're going to talk a little bit more about correlation measures. We've
already mentioned r squared. Remember, r squared gives us the strength of the
relationship between two variables. Sometimes r squared is called the
coefficient of determination. Because r squared is a proportion, it ranges from
0 to 1. And our r squared value of 0 means that the variables are not at all
related. And our r squared of 1 means they are perfectly related. This rarely
ever happens in everyday life. It's hard to imagine variables that are
perfectly related. When conducting the t test, the formula for r squared can be
derived from the information from our t test. The formula for our r squared is
t squared over t squared plus our degrees of freedom. The t here is not the
critical value, it's the value we get from the t test itself. In computing r
squared, all we have to do is compute our t value from the formula, square it,
put that in the numerator, square it again, add our degrees of freedom and then
divide.